yeah hello and welcome to this video i'm
restarting this this video I thought my
opponent wouldn't play a move but
ultimately he he played one right after
I suggested an award okay but instead of
aborting with being down on time he
decided to continue or play the game for
real so we'll see we'll see what happens
okay castle and yeah just play no moose
I could play rook e8 first and then but
should be six but I think yeah the main
problem for black in this type of
position is to to get something active
if you're somewhat dissatisfied with the
draw and in blitz you tend to tend to be
a bit bit more ambitious let's say then
then over the board chess where I draw
quite often it's not so bad well it
let's say you want to be what they have
some entertainment i guess and this is
difficult to get in this kind of this
kind of opening okay i went e5 and you
went night f5 yeah I can't just take
there's nothing particularly wrong with
that we came so I'm going to take
mmm yeah b7 is not not really hanging I
wonder if Queen two is six is a
potential move because I take takes 93
okay again he can do that I have some
play against f2 this is what it's
certainly possible here yeah okay I'll
play some place up slow moves it is
difficult to get something going here as
I said that point wasn't hanging but I
thought it's still kind of useful move
to make so yeah I can go to e6 but it's
not an ideal ideal move to make so let's
do this shoot for looky age and
potentially 26 then yeah it's not so
easy actually okeee does maybe Bishop
takes h6 rather rather rather knowing
again I hope the eight is all-sufficient
h6 should have gone to e8 that would
have been a little bit more a little bit
more effective okay well this is not
what I wanted originally but I probably
have to accept that the pawn structure
will be a little bit devalued
still not a big deal i believe my
development this is quite okay so okay
he took it so any ways to use that time
advantage that have i can actually take
and go here for the sake of equality
okay if I take H 2 there is f 3 I guess
so that was a was a good move yeah how
to activate my nighty knight on c6 this
is not a good piece and probably I go
back
try to reroute this to f6 or g6 it's
definitely not we have placed on c6 985
there must be threesome
yeah neither for is an idea so expect
him to play 92 after which I ok so chick
doesn't lead to much should have thought
about this for four movement at least
it's really not very effective neither
form
yeah it's not particularly great not
great at all the any counter play that I
can go for it's not easy at all maybe
back and it's not not fun
I'm a clear route you one but I have be
five then I don't mind that much NM head
on the clock now time morning so i have
t 5 or potentially look CA but I think I
go with you five it's more
straightforward so deform
yeah cookie form check
I Scott Lucas is six in this position
that's a bit of a shame Jack don't care
Jeff bra our third game drama no effect
kind of silly to play this forward I
have to have been bad the whole game so
I offered to draw I mean not bad but it
was kind of an inspiring here it is
probably equal with good flavor i gifted
him too many tempe with his stupid moves
like this he had God's it's got social
acrylic oh now he's got the FR because
this is the problem I have no good
continuation in maybe g5 is a month but
why does better him my pawns are just
weaker yeah I played it right after the
opening I think I played a little bit
inaccurate lane and this is ok I believe
and also this is ok so let's start
starting somewhere here I can definitely
improve yeah this is probably just a
stupid move I mean what I'm wasn't sure
of is if this is possible because I
thought he might be able to take but
this is a strong rules that i did not
see ok and then this is pretty much the
way to equalize grew piedra Queenie 6
because here I void any double points
and this is just completely equal and
Diego ok i can go create six here
probably yeah gaining and maybe gaining
time I don't know me it's funny that the
engine likes my position here yeah maybe
this is a stupid idea i mean if i don't
get if i don't get a pawn on the desired
traits this is what's given by the
computer try that makes quite some sense
actually ig6 yeah that's okay i mean
this is what the computer wants to do
with threatening this and this is this
is kind of active yeah yeah I'm not
worse so this is a stupid move Jim I
just cannot take h2 and those traits
they are they are the better for wide
end with my further inaccuracies that
neither 4 and so on his advantage just
increased over time okay well thanks for
watching